-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy and Golden Globe winning
comedian you know from his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
Palm Springs, and is one third
of The Lonely Island.
He stars in "Brooklyn 99,"
which returns tomorrow night
at 8 for it's final season
right here on NBC.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Andy Samberg.
-Oh, uh, actually, Seth, yeah,
I'm trying a new character.
-You're trying a new character?
-Yeah, it's a new character.
It's really good,
can you just read the card
you're about to be handed?
-And now,
here with a health update,
please welcome esteemed
immunologist Dr. Faucberg.
-[ Sighs ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey, Seth,
what an honor to be here.
-So, uh, Dr. Faucberg, is it
safe to say you're
no relation to Dr. Fauci?
-He's my fifth cousin.
-Oh, really? I've never heard
of a fifth cousin.
-Yeah, it's when only the start
of your last name is the same.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah, so, like,
famous fifth cousins would be.,
Bruce Springsteen
and Rick Springfield.
-Yeah.
-Or Barack Obama and Steve-O.
-What?
-What? We can both say "what"
when the other person's
being crazy, Seth.
Sorry to steal the go-to arrow
from your quiver.
-Okay, so. So, Dr. Faucberg --
-Dr. Andthony Faucberg, yes.
-Your first name is "And"-thony?
-It is.
I'm sixth cousins with
Andy Samberg
because our first names
start the same.
-Dr. Andthony Faucberg,
is it safe to assume
you're here to talk to us about
the coronavirus?
-No, Seth. I'm here to talk to
you about a new virus.
A virus more deadly
than any we have ever seen
in the field of science or any
of the other fields.
-The other fields?
-Wrigley, Sally, W.C.
-What's the new virus?
-The Frisbee virus.
-Oh, [Bleep] off, Andy.
-Hey! Leave my cousin outta this
he has nothing to do with this.
-What's, what's
the Frisbee virus?
-It's a matter of life and death
and it's easy to catch.
-And how do you catch it?
-All you have to do is
take one look
at your ugly-ass dog Frisbee
and you know you have it
if you throw up right away.
-Mm-hmm.
-Which is why,
if you think you're at risk
of seeing a Frisbee,
you have to mask up.
Let me show you the proper
technique.
-Okay.
-Just like that.
You see, Seth?
You see how it works?
This is what you do when you
don't want to see Frisbee.
-Are you gonna keep that mask on
for the rest of the interview?
-Uh, no. I am not, because I
have not memorized this script.
It's hot off the presses.
-How -- How did
the Frisbee virus start?
-Ah, good setup question, Seth,
thank you.
She was either purchased
at a wet market,
which makes sense,
because she looks like a wet rat
or she was created in a lab,
which also makes sense,
because no god would make such
a foul creature.
-Sure. Sure.
-Next question of course
would be did she escape
from a lab?
-Yeah.
-I don't think that's likely.
-You don't think that's likely?
-No.
I think it's more likely that
someone who worked at the lab
said this dog sucks,
we should let her out,
and then say she escaped.
And then everyone agreed to that
plan because, you know.
[ Sniffs ] She sucks.
-Are we done?
-Wait, hold on, hold on!
Uh, let me see. Oh, you need a
super strong vaccine
for the Frisbee virus,
because she suck so much.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah, it's like way stronger
than Johnson & Johnson.
-Mm-hmm.
But do you want to know what
vaccine is way stronger
than Johnson & Johnson?
-No.
Dwayne "The Rock"
Johnson & Johnson.
Did that work with the crew,
Seth?
-[ Laughs ]
-Just let me know if that played
with the crew.
I'm dying to know.
-I think we can probably
wrap this up now.
-Yeah.
Uh, when they play me on "SNL"
I wanted it to Clooney.
I know that you're allowed to
call it now,
so I want it to be Clooney.
-Please give it up
for Dr. Andthony Faucberg.
We'll be right back
with Andy Samberg.
-My cousin!